[Norvig] Okay, now let's go on to the straight and flush functions.
The first thing to do, of course, is to add more tests.
In this case, I won't make you write them. I'm going to write them myself.
I've written 4 tests here.
I should be much more exhaustive than this, but I wanted to have 1 true
and 1 false for each of the 2 cases.
Remember a straight takes as input a list of ranks, not a hand or list of cards.
And so 9, 8, 7, 6, 5, yes, that is a straight.
9, 8, 8, 6, 5. That's got a pair; it's not a straight, and so that should be false.
As for flushes, the straight flush which had all clubs, that should be true.
That should be a flush.
And the 4 of a kind which had all 4 different suits should not be a flush.
I've written the tests. Now it's your turn to write the code.
I want you to write straight, which should return True
if the ordered ranks form a 5-card straight and False otherwise,
and flush, which should return True if all the cards in the hand have the same suit
and False otherwise.